dabei ist luca manager haben und herren
wir spielen heute gemeinsam ein spiel
auf einem kanal dass ich vor einigen
jahren schon mal gespielt habe und zwar
trägt das spiel den titel stealing
diamond2 dem spiel geht es darum dass
wir dieser stick man hier sind wir
müssen wahrscheinlich diesen diamanten
hier klar würde ich sagen klicke ich
direkt auf play wir sehen schon das bild
wird schwarz und stimmt die lahmann
einer ziemlich lang voll also wir sehen
im fernsehen dass es einen neuen
diamanten gibt er ausgestellt wird wir
schnappen uns unsere autoschlüssel und
fahren zu dem museum hin wo das ganze
ding neben falschen mitteln auf dem berg
okay er wieder brechen richtig krass ein
oder bis nieten uns rein
ja ich will zu anderen großen knall ich
weiß nicht was er hier vorbereitet hat
für den großen knall aber es hat auf
jeden fall ein reifen es hat einen
auspuff also ich weiß nicht was das ist
ich habe zu spät gedrückt also ich
drücke dafür klicken und das hat nicht
geklappt jetzt drücke ich mal er zum
rammen und wir sind zu brennen
aber da ist das egal ob richards-ross
action man muss ziemlich schnell wie
herr kind bei der scheiße also wir sind
richtig jetzt einfach mal auf mails also
auf dieses geschäft
hanging around and you something ja
danke versuche ich ja ich wusste gar
nicht mehr dass das spiel so stressig
ist wichtig jetzt mal auf die lanze und
mit der langsamer er stellt sich war
nicht so klug an also die beiden rechten
sachen habe ich draußen will das heißt
nehme jetzt mal das schild und gesehen
schon mit dem wir sind weiter die sind
dann über next topmodel an den diamanten
brannten
er verlor da waren
ich dachte ich dachte es wäre schon
vorbei also die fahnderin von diamanten
jetzt vor der polizei hier weg und wir
haben die möglichkeit häufig nehmen
wie schnell muss man sich bei der kette
denn entscheiden also ich denke jetzt
ganz schnell einfach auf rock so wir
nehmen einen stein der abt mit
umschmeißen auf die polizei ruf nach
verstärkungen wir haben hier oben drei
sterne aber jetzt kommt daher liegt ein
helikopter wie ich denke mal auf babbel
wenn das klappt auch jetzt sind wir im
tunnel sind an dem tunnel vorbei und da
hinten ist auch mein gott ok ein loch in
der bürger dafür müssen uns jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder entscheiden oder
haben wir damit
[Applaus]
ja ja geschafft
[Musik]
das weiß relativ schnell das tolle an
dem spiel ist allerdings dass es
verschiedene wege gibt und das ganze
durch zu spielen das heißt ich klicke
jetzt einfach mal aufs nick in also wir
schleichen uns langsam heran
wir haben einige möglichkeiten als rein
zu kommen bevor wir es gleich mit der
ersten möglichkeit anfangen um in das
gebäude zu kommen allerdings eine ganz
kurze zwischen sache und zwar so immer
eine neue podcast folge dick und doof
mit sandra online gegangen sandra bringt
mir mehr oder weniger russisch bei also
ein link in der infobox das gerne an und
jetzt testen wie die erste mindestgebot
ski ich will sagen wir tasten als erstes
mal die ampel hoppers mit denen sollen
mehr angebliche hoch springen können
das braucht das war ja das war nicht so
schlau als nächstes teste ich mal den
anti gravity capital ltd anti gravity
kemfert wir können darauf klicken und
dann wird die schwerkraft ausgesetzt hat
jetzt auch nicht so geklappt das heißt
als nächstes wichtig mal auf den
teleporter das sollte ja eigentlich
relativ gut funktionieren weil wir sind
wir sind weg wir sind
oben
oh ich hätte
gedacht dass das funktioniert wir haben
jetzt einen penny wir haben einen
tranquilizer was aber das ist ja am
garten falsch und wir haben im wesen wie
genau ich würde sagen ich nehme die
visibilität als vision locken die pille
werden unsichtbar und es hat ja ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal den fall
kampusch also ich muss ihnen das ok das
hat nicht geklappt das ist jetzt mal den
tranquilizer wasserkühler was auch immer
das ist er nicht
[Musik]
ich bin ziemlich beschissen gerade die
letzte möglichkeit die wir haben ist der
penny also damit müssten wir das
anscheinend schaffen
das heißt er schon auf dem penny und wir
sind direkt beim diamanten okay ich
klicke einfach mal auf portugal
die kann man auf dem spieleportal
zweiter kann jetzt sagen portal machen
und jetzt machen wir eine orangene
portal daten genau das dass auch wir
sind wir waren jetzt zwischen den
portalen und sind da hin und her also
porträt kann klappt nicht das heißt ich
nehme mir zu war ja das hatten wir
aufholen auch bei dem aggressiven weg
genommen allerdings nutzen jetzt gerade
um uns abzuschreiben und wir sind dann
eben das heißt wenn wir zwei
möglichkeiten wieder der lasercard neben
den weit bin ja laser lukas also er
nimmt den laser kater setzt ihn drauf
sorry aber so vom baum gefallen oder was
dann geht es ja nur mit dem hammer meine
lieben freunde das heißt ich glaube
jetzt auf den hammer und scheint ist der
diamant direkt frei wir können an den
leuten neben wir sind noch nicht an den
leuten vorbei wir realisieren aber
gerade dass dort leute sind und wir
haben eine kanone wir haben käse und wir
haben einen plan
so blöd es klingt ich klicke auf den
käse wir essen den käse
warum habe ich mir gedacht dass wir mit
einem käse an zwei wächtern vorbeikommen
aber gut dann klicke ich halte auch die
kanone also das was man wirklich
eigentlich an
erst mein gott das ist das nicht gut
das
das war nicht so schlau dann muss es ja
eigentlich nach holzstück richten so
blöd sich das anhört aber ist sieht ganz
gut aus
sie sind wahrscheinlich sind wir genau
auf dem ding gelandet
ich würde auf deinen klicken dass wir
den diamanten einfach runter schmeißt
den typen
da
ok endlich habe ich noch was geschafft
hier ja noch den sinn geschafft
ich würde allerdings gerne mal wissen ob
es noch einen weiteren weg gibt und zwar
klicke ich wieder aufs nie gehen und
jetzt haben wir hier die möglichkeiten
mit dem wir nach oben kommen und mit
denen wir in der seite rein kommen also
ich nehme mal das ding und versuchen
mich klein zu machen und jetzt komme ich
nämlich durch diesen kleinen eigenen ja
wahrscheinlich werden wir dann von einem
regenwurm aufgefressen dann versuche ich
jetzt mal mit der pigs also dass wir
einfach versuchen uns davon einen krieg
kommen
wir sind drin
ich nehme die waffe also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass das klappt aber ich habe
die frau die waffe war vielleicht nicht
mehr so aktuell als nächstes entscheide
ich mich mal hier für diese bombshell
schmeißt es auch sein
ja warum sollten die auf funktionierende
bomben in einem museum ausstellen luca
dh die letzte option die wir jetzt noch
haben ist flugzeug damit habe ich jetzt
den eintippen he rum und der andere
versucht das flugzeug zu fangen und er
läuft gegen die säule das heißt wir sind
jetzt in den nächsten dings und wir
müssen uns jetzt entscheiden ob er den
grand exit gehen oder investieren kann
ich
so ganz
kommt also ich
ich habe es daran liegt dass der typ
dann anscheinend nicht mehr so richtig
guckt wenn man wenn die teile angezeigt
werden aber ich denke jetzt ganz schnell
da drauf und wir haben es geschafft
okay wir sind im nächsten raum
ich mach die tür auf und sie den
diamanten dahinter die sache ist
allerdings da sind zwei wärter das haben
jetzt verschiedene mit
wir haben einen meteoriten eine kuba
einen pokal und einen super pilz ich
denke einfach mal auf den pop idol weil
ich das einfach sehen will jetzt sogar
sonne
jetzt kommt sogar seine pokémon
animation ich liebe diese reihe von
spielen dass es so nah ist ein paar
sekunden später
das hat nicht ganz geklappt
wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal ganz
schlicht die probe das ist schon sehr
gut animiert das heißt es könnte richtig
sein er mehr
[Applaus]
ja es hat doch nicht so ganz geklappt
als nächstes nehmen wir jetzt mal den
meteoriten ich mich kenne wird auch das
wieder falsch ein und nur die letzte bin
ich denn so schlecht dass ich so häufig
nur die letzte sache dann das ja also
der supermacht muss es ja erst
anscheinend richten wir werden doppelt
oder dreifach so gut ist jedenfalls
schon so wie das hier gerade auf youtube
schießt uns ab aber bringt ich bin
riesig ich bin der maschine sowie ich
wenn ich ins fitnessstudio gehe da waren
sogar die dinosaurier aufgeben ich
versuche mich mit kanonen abzuwehren die
cetera pp ab ich dachte ich bin
dschawwad gekümmert
aber ich finde das ganze museum ist am
arsch und jetzt bin ich
irgend einen knopf drücken dass ich
getötet werde
oh ich bin einen knopf drücken
ich sage denen die sie den strom ich
habe ich habe keine sekunde
ich hab alles was passiert jetzt
hä
ich hätte nicht wo wir sind bei dem
spiel ich drücke jetzt mal das hier ich
habe keine ahnung was da passiert hier
die kirchen taschenrechner und der tipp
was jetzt darin richtig sehen wir jetzt
mal den satelliten hier vermutlich ist
das auch wieder falsch also dass
irgendein satelliten mitten im weltraum
und er saugt gegen was an und das heißt
es muss er jetzt wieder das letzte sein
ich finde es so krass dass ich da sind
vier auswahlmöglichkeiten und war bisher
in diesem video fast immer der ball das
ist die ersten drei genommen habe die
falsch waren
hier soll ein riesiger roter der alles
durch sie verdammen ich mit dem
diamanten
und da hat der ausgang
ok jetzt bin ich aus der puste und dr
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung was ich hier
gerade gespielt habe okay bis dann
[Musik]